esik has published their investigation
into claims by former heroic coach
hundin that players were complicit in
his use of the coaching bug the report
concluded that the evidence provided was
insufficient to prove that the players
were complicit with one major exception
shortly after heroic published a video
of their own and these accounts of the
players telling their side of the story
were honestly a little difficult to
watch
let's take a look at the likely end of
the heroic coaching bug saga
[Music]
hey if you like not having to read
through esic reports and instead
watching a video about it consider
liking this video about an esic report
subscribing to the channel and ringing
the notification bell me
i love this stuff i don't know why i
think i must be broken okay there are a
lot of moving parts here so let's get
caught up quickly at the end of august
2020 hunden along with over 30 other cs
go coaches was banned for his use of a
coaching bug which allowed him to
spectate live matches using a bugged pov
the bug basically let the coach get
their camera into a position of their
choice on the map and they could rotate
the camera freely in any direction in
hunton's case he used the bug in only
two official matches one against
astralis and another against spirit the
initial ban was for 12 months but
because he cooperated with the esports
integrity commission or esic it was
reduced to eight months he also came
clean and admitted that the other
players had no idea he was using the bug
during the ban hunden couldn't work as
heroic's coach but it does appear that
he continued to do analyst work for the
organization and at the end of the eight
month period in april 2021 he was
reinstated as coach however in july 2021
heroic released hunden saying that there
were trust issues and that an
investigation had concluded that he had
shared confidential strategic
information with a competitor in the
lead-up to iem cologne heroic also said
that they had started legal proceedings
in denmark in august 2021 a year after
the initial coaching bug ban isic banned
him for two more years for sharing that
information hunton denied the
allegations at first but then said he
hadn't shared heroic's own strategies
but instead anti-strat information about
how to handle opponents it's not really
clear that this distinction mattered in
any way to esic but a few days later
hunden changes story about the coaching
bug which is why we're talking about
this again this time he alleged that
heroic's players knew about his use of
the coaching bug and that he had
essentially been asked to take the fall
to protect heroics players he made this
announcement on danish television
channel tv2 and at the time esik
responded that they had yet to receive
any evidence from hunden supporting
these claims
but they did open an investigation into
it and on october 18th it was
declassified by esic so that takes us to
now the report is finally public and
while there are some interesting
revelations in there hunden definitely
did not get the outcome he wanted the
first thing to note is that the report
concludes that the evidence provided by
hunden fails to prove that cadian borup
tessus or staun quote were guilty of any
offense under the esic integrity program
but nikolai nico christensen one of the
team's players did admit to knowing
about the cheating and has been punished
however in light of the report's
conclusions and as part of a plea deal
arrangement the severity of that
punishment has been greatly reduced the
consequences are quote one a severe
public reprimand for his behavior two a
warning as to future conduct with severe
consequences for any future breach of
the easic integrity program three
mandatory attendance at two one-on-one
education sessions with the esa
commissioner of minimum 30 minutes
duration each
four a minimum 15-minute check-in with
the commissioner every month for a
minimum of six months to ensure he has
understood and is complying with the
e-sic integrity program and to offer him
support for any issues he might be
having in this respect they also note
that quote any failure to abide by the
conditions of the plea bargain outlined
above will result in a minimum 30 day
ban from all e6 member events so why
extend this leniency to nico if he knew
well the report says that niko's case
was exceptional he has adhd and
asperger's syndrome and is additionally
quote heavily dependent on the people he
trusts he is naive and by his own
admission in conjunction with the
objective evidence collated in the
course of the investigation and
inquiries into the implications of his
conditions
trust too easily mr christensen trusted
and respected mr peterson implicitly and
mr peterson observably deliberately
fostered and then exploited that trust
at a timing that was convenient to him
so the report goes on to say that nico
trusted hundin mr peterson in the
previous paragraph and that he didn't
want to rock the boat bringing up an
issue when it was someone that he
trusted nico himself made a short
statement on twitter about the fact that
he never wanted to discuss these
diagnoses in public but
it had become unavoidable he also humbly
accepted the punishments in the report
one of the key things hunden presented
as evidence was a phone recording and
accompanying transcript where nico
appears to agree that all the other
players knew about the cheating perhaps
not before the first match but
definitely after we'll get to that claim
in a second but given the
characterization of this phone call in
the report it's definitely something we
should discuss reading from the report
quoting comment from esa commissioner
ian smith quote in particular i believe
that the much publicized text and phone
conversations in july 2021 with mr
peterson demonstrates that mr
christensen was ruthlessly manipulated
and set up by mr peterson in an attempt
to force mr christensen to verbally
commit to a position which would
incriminate both himself and his former
teammates for smith it's not just the
words in the transcript that matter it's
the timing of the phone call and the
tone that hunden used while talking to
nico
this conversation initiated by mr
peterson and recorded by him in july of
this year after mr peterson became aware
that esic was investigating his sharing
of heroics data without mr christensen's
knowledge or permission shows only two
things of relevance to me first that mr
christensen is being set up to aid mr
peterson's agenda to cause harm to
heroic and second that mr christensen
assumes without knowing that his former
teammates knew about the spectator bug
at the time of those matches more than a
year earlier this is not in my view a
basis for concluding that they actually
knew so e6 view is that hundin realized
he was being investigated set up a phone
call with nico and in that phone call he
tried to pressure him to say yes of
course everybody was involved with the
cheating the response video i mentioned
earlier actually addresses hunden's
claim that everyone knew in it the
players say that they found out about
the cheating after the first match
against astralis where he used it
first off thought it was like a joke it
was a few hours after the game we just
lost it and nico started
saying that hunton has used this
coachbuck we were very shocked
and
we really gave
our opinion about this subject and said
that there was under no circumstances
that this bug should be used and how
stupid it was if hunting's only argument
was that three of the players were aware
he had cheated
after the lost astralis match then i
guess they've admitted to that but esik
says that his contention is that they
were complicit in the cheating not just
that they knew so again some of the
players knew
after the astralis match that hunden had
cheated but they told him never to do it
again that it wasn't okay what the
report calls a quote clear stand against
cheating end quote and apparently borup
and tessus were never told about this
situation and management was seemingly
never informed when we told him
that this box should under no
circumstances be used in the game again
we trusted that he would not do so
and that's also why it was not
communicated to borob and tessa's that
the buck had been used which looking
back at it we should have and we should
probably have the team meeting and said
what what the [ __ ] is going on here i
think we can all agree that it was a
huge mistake for the players not to make
the others aware but for esik at least
hunden failed to prove that the players
minus nico were complicit in his
cheating scheme in any way the report
also confirmed something else alleged by
hunden to tv2 and then discussed at
length in the counter-strike community
which was the fact that heroic tried to
have its players sign an nda or
non-disclosure agreement about this
whole situation but if the organization
attempted to have the players sign this
nda and it would prevent discussion of
this entire incident
why have they not faced any consequences
the esic report says that because of big
changes to both management and ownership
at heroic since the coaching bug scandal
quote it is important to distinguish
this statement's indication of failings
and poor decisions by the previous
management administering the
organization at the time of the
spectator bug scandal from the current
ownership and management team the nda
was also seemingly a reaction to the
august 2020 ban and not to some
revelations of cheating surfacing after
the astralis match where it was first
used by hunden which the report says
they didn't hear about the nda is
painted as a misguided pr effort and not
a total cover-up attempt in the report
in heroic's response video cadian says
that he was against any attempts by the
old management or ownership to have the
players sign an nda because it could
limit their ability to defend themselves
so they didn't sign it hunton wanted
this nda signed but i was fighting
against it and i even remember there was
some like
argument about it but
i was very
strong in my belief that this india
should not be signed and that's why it
wasn't the last thing that bears
discussing is the use of the bug the
second time in the match against spirit
where tessus apparently helped boost
hunden a few times before the match
started this understandably raised some
concerns if tesis wasn't cooperating
with hunden why help boost him before
the match tessa said in the response
video that he wasn't aware that anything
he was doing was connected in any way to
cheating and as cadian said in the
response video tesis wasn't made aware
of the use of the bug after it happened
the first time there are some other
minor interesting details in the report
including a credible witness brought in
by hunden but who could only prove that
hunden said that he thought the players
knew
which isn't the same as them
actually no and if you're interested in
stuff like this i'd recommend taking a
look through
i'm kind of a nerd for this stuff so i
get it but i want to end this video by
talking a little bit about honda i mean
the guy cheated he admitted it to three
of his teammates and those teammates
didn't feel the need to turn him in or
at least make the other players and the
organization aware of that fact even if
they later regretted it you may have
only heard the name hunden in connection
with the incidents like the ones we just
talked about and if that's the case
you'd certainly be forgiven for that for
much of the cs go era it's not exactly
like hunden was fragging out on
denmark's top teams and that's before
considering the fact that denmark had a
pretty rough go of things at the very
beginning of cs go but what hunden was
certainly was a massive influence on
danish cs go he was considered one of
the great minds of the region and
respected by many of his peers listen i
don't just host videos i primarily write
them so when i was researching to write
the story of glaive and read an article
in dot esports where glaive credited
hunden with helping both himself and msl
become great in-game leaders
that's high praise and i knew i had to
talk to him to know exactly
how that happened furthermore a report
from luis mira then working for hltv in
july 2021 cited sources that claimed
hunden was a front-runner to become the
coach of astralis after sonic's contract
expired i guess what i'm trying to say
is that it's no surprise that hunden was
trusted by his players he was trusted by
most players in his region hunton had
quite a big status in the danish scene
before joining heroic he was like kind
of the godfather of danishes like he was
the guy that everyone was talking about
i'm not trying to cover the three heroic
players for staying quiet after that
astralis match
they made that decision but i at least
understand why they hesitated and with
all of this in the rearview mirror i
hope they can realize that the decision
that damaged hunden's career was his own
and if they could have all understood
that back then they could have spared
themselves a lot of anguish
i remember like i'm pretty sure like
when the when the coaching bug was first
discovered right
they had like two people
going through everything and it's like
thousands of matches
like like there's a lot to keep on top
of and nobody you know then no or even a
super well-funded organization
would have trouble
keeping track of all of it and trying to
stay on top of cheating i mean esic also
is responsible um for administering uh
drug tests at events um it's wild to
think about and it's not something that
you see in
you know like like you know in sports a
franchise league carries out its own
drug test and carries out its own
investigations if it must for whatever
reason right so
um
it's it's just it's so difficult and big
respect to the guys at esic